ce
il est 7 heures du matin au mont saint
michel bazin touristes à l'horizon
pourtant iain guelton 70 ans est déjà
sur le pont l'adjoint au maire vient
d'être appelé en urgence
bonjour speed ya toujours des problèmes
aussi et ce matin le problème est de
taille
une odeur nauséabonde vient d'envahir la
rue ça serai là à peu près d'accord chez
un commerçant la canalisation des
toilettes a cassé il faut trouver d'où
vient la fuite
aujourd'hui on tire les pavés en cause
pour réparer tout ce qui stresse yann
galt on sait comment faire passer les
touristes avec ces travaux
les premiers vont arriver dans trois
heures laisse un petit passage en pleine
saison
les touristes peuvent être jusqu'à 20000
chaque jour à emprunter cette petite rue
la seule qui mène à l'abbaye
autant dire qu'on interrompe à le trafic
pour moi est un objectif primordial que
ce soit toujours
voilà voilà c'est comme ça on se
débrouille on gère faut que je vois
toujours ouvert mais dans ses rues
étroites du moyen-âge cela va prendre un
peu de temps
l'adjoint commencent à s'inquiéter
j'essaie de me rappeler vite fait s'il
te plaît d'urgence a pris trois heures
de travaux impossible de trouver cette
maudite fuite est le premier groupe de
touristes arrivent déjà des japonais
mais pas question pour autant de se
montrer stressé il faut faire bonne
figure
[Musique]
les touristes sont obligés de se
faufiler pour continuer leur parcours
non non je laisse passer
un coup dur en pleine saison pour
l'image du mont saint michel un des
sites les plus visités au monde
[Musique]
rocher d'un kilomètre carré
le mont saint michel est un trait
d'union entre la bretagne et la
normandie
un site exceptionnel classé au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
connu et reconnu pour son joyau l'abbaye
du mont saint michel
déjà dès le 14e siècle on y venait en
pèlerinage comme à rome ou à saint
jacques de compostelle
aujourd'hui le mont-saint-michel attire
chaque année 3 millions de touristes du
monde entier
après paris c'est le deuxième site le
plus visité de france
depuis une semaine la famille o'byrne
marche à travers chants accompagnés de
taquin un âne du poitou il a sauté la
près de 20 kilomètres par jour
mais ce matin david and et leurs trois
enfants touchent leur but presque lui
doit garder les enfants il est là voilà
le mont saint michel
vous le voyez bien à portée de main le
mont-saint-michel leur terre promise
[Musique]
plus on se rapproche du mont plus les
monumentales c'est ça qui est
impressionnant michel est très beau en
louant c'est anne cette famille
lyonnaise voulez revivre l'épopée des
pèlerins d'antan fait monter la plus que
quelques kilomètres avant d'atteindre
leur but mais ce matin ce n'est pas
capucine cinq ans ou joséphine six ans
qui traîne la patte mais taquin qui fait
sa tête de mule
[Musique]
allez on y va
après 120 km de marche et des nuits
passées à la belle étoile
la famille a hâte d'arriver mais elle va
vite déchanter
bienvenue dans la civilisation
après sept jours de solitude et
davanture nous voilà arrivés pendant un
milieu urbain au pied du mont l'ambiance
n'est pas celle des pèlerins du moyen
âge mais aux milliers de touristes
équipés d'appareils photo
la famille devient carrément
l'attraction ça c'est plus du tout pour
l'année pour le touriste poussez-vous
attention
annan
voilà pour taquin c'est la fin du voyage
bonjour aujourd'hui
question sécurité il faudra rester ici
d'incarner très bien absolument d'accord
battez vous voyez rennes bat ici c'est
pas pour nous c'est exceptionnel ou non
après avoir rendu service à toute la
famille
taquin fini son périple dans ce camion
remorque il repart avec son propriétaire
dans l'unique et étroite rue du monde
le pire est à venir difficile d'avancer
c'est l'embouteillage sur 300 m bien
loin de la paix intérieure qu'ils
étaient venus chercher
seule solution pour s'extirper de cette
marée humaine c'est de prendre de la
hauteur et de gravir les 350 marche qui
mène à l'abbaye du mont saint michel
un parcours très sportif un tiers des
touristes abandonne ton chemin mais au
sommet une vue imprenable sur la baie du
mont saint michel
[Musique]
si l'on fait tous ces kilomètres c'est
pour admirer le joyau du rocher l'abbaye
un monastère millénaire empreint
d'histoire c'est saint-aubert c'est
l'évêque d'avranches
joséphine vient de prendre cinq verres
l'évêque d'avranches en photo l'évêque
saint-aubert
si le mont-saint-michel existe c'est un
peu grâce à lui
comme le rappelle ce vitrail en 708
c'était vrai qu auraient reçu l'ordre de
l'archange saint-michel de construire
sur le mans un édifice à la gloire de
dieu
au bout du troisième rappel il fini par
s'exécuter et ordonne la construction de
l'abbaye le rocher de granit fut alors
appelé mont saint michel
une merveille de l'occident mais surtout
une sacrée source de tracas pour jan
galle ton l'adjoint au maire nous le
retrouvons 150 mètres plus bas à lui
tendue que jamais comme un élève avant
une interro à bages arrive je vais sort
je suis à vous il a rendez vous avec un
homme qui ne plaisante pas avec le
patrimoine c'est l'architecte des
bâtiments de france
monsieur germaine le mont saint michel
va être passée au crible toute
transformation des bâtiments doit être
validé par l'architecte et l'homme et du
genre pointilleux
pour l'un pour pour la restauration lors
des couleurs des façades au choix des
tuiles jusqu'à l'emplacement précis des
gouttières l'élève galt on se fait
remonter les bretelles
le look est bon alors par contre là il a
tout faux
rien n'échappe à l'architecte qui ne
veut voir que du style médiéval
alors quand il tombe sur ce
défibrillateur en plastique
il est au bord de la crise cardiaque ça
c'est la limite des systèmes le
défibrillateur apparences on parle
beaucoup c'est vrai c'est bon c'est bon
c'est pas bon mais c'est obligatoire
c'est quand même si on était capable de
trouver quelque chose d'un petit peu
plus discret d'un peu plus élégant et de
le dégager par rapport à la lecture de
l'architecturé de la maison sucden
un détail par rapport au reste le vrai
problème ce sont les commerçants qui
prennent certaines libertés
[Musique]
dans la rue principale les pancartes
publicitaires se sont multipliés c'est à
celui qui aura la plus grosse et ça ça
ne convient pas du tout à monsieur
germaine quand je vois cette enseigne là
et comme je vois un de froid
sur le même endroit 4 à faire le même
endroit e
il ya un problème que le mot soit
une aire commerçante membres évident que
les gens viennent aussi chercher sa vie
viennent pas chercher du moche face à
ces remontrances l'adjoint au maire en
caisse obligé de jouer les fayots mais
je suis entièrement d'accord moi je
j'aime bien que le mont-saint-michel
soit clean présentable et pour monsieur
guelton le supplice est loin d'être
terminée
quelques mètres plus loin les
commerçants se sont étalés sur les murs
de l'église
l'architecte voit rouge
la sanction est sous le diet je pense
qu'il faut qu'on les fasse décrocher
l'heure du grand ménage a sonné et une
fois de plus c'est l'adjoint au maire
qui va s'y coller ce qui ne l'enchanté
pas vraiment moi je vais avoir des gros
problèmes après parce que tous les
commerçants qui vont tomber dessus je
vais vous dire que ça va être costaud
germaine ou plaisir le problème c'est
que si les commerçants ne transige pas
ils s'exposent à des amendes
alors pour les convaincre l'adjoint au
maire il va sur la pointe des pieds il
tente sa chance avec madame frameries la
vendeuse de souvenirs je peux voir deux
petites secondes de jeu germaine
impressions photos oui parce que ça lui
a perforé pour voir ça il veut voir ces
pierres par contre je suis d'accord avec
lui mais sauf que ça ce sont des
articles qui sont lourds et s'en est
soucié losc est donc si vous mettez une
grille en face à ce repas est pris sur
10 ans ferrat j'aimerais quand même
froid pour ce que germaine et comme du
souci est qu'il ya un client qui
reçoivent les gargouilles conso objet
d'attaqués me surprennent c'est quand
même dommage
madame frameries joue l'ironie car ici
l'architecte ne fait pas peur il y en a
deux en particulier qui ne se laisse pas
faire les restaurateurs au franc parler
légendaire
frédéric fidèle dit fredo et sa femme
légèrement ce mardi par deux compagnies
la wii
l'ami préféré à nani
j'ai passé bien le voir les façades en
pierre
et moi j'aime mieux moi je l'aimé c'est
un monsieur qui montrent la rue du mont
saint michel le bot ceci je compte cela
je pense aussi mais il n'y a jamais eu
si vite possible c'est pas mon temps
c'est pas mignon au sein du jeu fredo
personne ne viendra jamais lui donner
d'ordres dans sa boutique ses pensées
ceci pousse trop à bout jour ça va péter
ça va péter
là bas la bombe et presto plancher de
trois ans quatre ans comme on dit ici le
commerce fait loi aujourd'hui le mont
saint michel est devenue une usine à
touristes où tout est fait pour vendre
c'est un peu ce que va découvrir notre
petite famille de marcheurs
après la visite de l'abbaye passage
obligé à la boutique de souvenirs
réclamé par les enfants comme des
millions de touristes année david vont
être obligés de mettre la main au
portefeuille
[Musique]
un truc un peu jolie qui ressemble au
mont saint michel a c'est pas le mont
saint michel c'est un public en choeur
mais qu'elle se rassure
ici elle l embarras du choix tassé
l'éffigie du rocher à 8 euros dé à
coudre à 5 euros donc décoratives pour 4
euros ou encore déléguant cadran
coquillages à 14 euros
le mont-saint-michel inspire remettre
leurs messages et madame frameries la
patronne a toujours la dernière
nouveauté qui peut faire plaisir celle
ci qui est avec un baril dégâts pas la
neige par contre si tu avais cabaret
comme ça devant et là ça fait
portefeuille ont pas mal cette rolex à
quel point j'aime bien le kitsch mais
modérément mais peu importe il faut
ramener un souvenir du monde je vais
prendre des cartes postales
les enfants eux en profitent pour en
rajouter un peu plus dans le panier
c'est là la panoplie chabrac celle bull
tu la trouves belle les payas lâche
aussi rien à voir avec le mont saint
michel
mais comme la plupart des parents année
david finissent par céder
au total entre le kitsch riz et les
épées de chevalier le couple s'en sort
tout de même pour 57 euros 20 ans et
enfante ont fait cet effort
non sa faute en or quel coût chaque
année trois millions de visiteurs
viennent remplir les tiroirs caisses des
commerçants 180 millions d'euros de
retombées touristiques que se partagent
un parti une dizaine de familles
historiques du mont bien assise sur leur
tas d'or
[Musique]
le lendemain midi au mont saint michel
nous retrouvons frédéric fidèles le
restaurateur au franc parler
wal fadjri chez ce cuisinier de 53 ans
ça dépote
demont faudra sauter cas avec sa femme
et sa fille il prépare jusqu'à 120
couverts chaque minute
dans une cuisine de quatre mètres carrés
et pas moyen de s'agrandir car comme
tous les autres commerces du monde son
restaurant été construit à même le
rocher qui s'était creusé carrément dans
le rocher
donc on voit que le rocher ici l'eau y
coule de partout ça cool ici aussi les
gens ils soient en signant ici
il croit que sa dignité et vous c'est
quoi bénéficier vous avez dans les
relances et de rochers sa famille est
installée sur le monde depuis 1783 huit
générations et il n'est pas peu fier
lacer mes aïeux se mon arrière arrière
grand père frédéric vidal ancien maire
du mont saint michel frey décrit dalle
moi je m'appelle frédérick raynal aussi
avec son épouse son patrimoine vaut de
l'or alors fredo s'y accrochent
férocement et des tests ce qui si on
appelle les hauts revenus
nombre de hordes de jeunes alors venu
vous êtes quelqu'un qui vient de
l'extérieur pour acheter chez nous on
vend les affaires entre nous si on a à
vendre sinon c'est de famille en famille
façon de famille en famille une
génération en génération
une histoire de famille dans l'étroite
rue du mont quasiment tous ses voisins
sont des cousins à deux pas de son
restaurant
sa cousine géraldine sien ce magasin de
souvenirs c'est la fille de la soeur de
mon père
jamais trahi à l'extérieur un peu plus
bas
marie-pierre elle s'est spécialisée dans
les crêpes celle à fait le frère de mon
père encore bricolent une bonne ambiance
et les familles unies en apparence
seulement
bandes de fréquences planque je m'étais
grande famine c'est une famille avec eux
plusieurs plans en réalité les familles
se livrent une guerre commerciale sans
pitié sur 300 mètres près de 50
commerces collés les uns aux autres se
disputent la manne touristique
c'est comme la série dallas côté famille
à gauche et à droite qui se tirent dans
les pattes disposent ils pensent le mont
saint michel un univers impitoyable
digne du feuilleton dallas
comme dans la série le rocher à son jr
l'homme de pouvoir que tout le monde
jalouse
eric vannier 60 ans berline de luxe
cheveux gominés pour remercier l'homme
règne en maître sur le monde et le pire
pour les natifs c'est qu'il n'est même
pas du rocher à part des vacances
scolaires passées ici
il a toujours vécu à paris aujourd'hui
c'est pourtant le maire du mont saint
michel
mais c'est surtout un redoutable homme
d'affaires depuis trente ans il
profiterait des dissensions familiales
pour acheter un par un tous les
commerces de l'île à un certain nombre à
gauche à droite devant derrière d avril
et là aussi c'est à c'est une auberge et
un hôtel reçu des hôtels des restaurants
mais pas seulement bon genre ça vient
aussi
c'est vrai on s'amusait sont des musées
mont saint michel
ils jouent les blasés mérite banier
possède en réalité un véritable empire
plus de vingt établissements un tiers
des commerces de l'île mais son coup de
maître
c'est d'avoir mis la main sur le
restaurant le plus convoité du rocher il
se trouve un peu plus bas à l'entrée du
monde
la mère poulard un restaurant aussi
célèbre que le rocher lui même renommé
pour cette omelette battu en rythme sa
préparation est un spectacle pour les
passes un batteur de père en fils un des
piliers de la maison une omelette bien
mousseuse qui attire des curieux du
monde entier et pour laquelle il faut
quand même débourser 39 euros alors à ce
prix là il vaut mieux qu'elle soit bonne
c'est fabuleux ça fait cher de l'heure
cette omelette a pourtant l'air simple à
préparer des oeufs du beurre le tout
cuit au feu de bois et un petit plus
tenu secret ça ne ment pas à la recette
elle est à la fois dans ma tête et dans
un coffre fort pour celui qui voudrait
me couper la tête
eric banny m entretenir le mystère
pourtant il n'a rien inventé cette
omelette a été créé en 1888 par un petit
bout de femme annette poulard
à l'époque pour a saisi les pèlerins
affamés après un long voyage
cette ancienne bonne heure près par une
omelette bien mousseuse
[Musique]
sa cuisine et sa réputation font vite le
tour du monde et l'auberge devient le
symbole gastronomique du mont saint
michel
dans les années 80 eric vannier a fait
fortune en rachetant des célèbres boîtes
de nuit parisiennes comme le palace où
les bains douches et quand l'auberge de
la mère poulard est à vendre
il met le paquet pour l'obtenir qu'à
l'époque il y avait trois possibilités
un groupe américain groupe japonais moi
donc je pensais qu'il fallait quand même
ça reste un peu français voilà tout
simplement donc j'ai j'ai cassé beaucoup
cassé ma tirelire qui était pas grosse à
l'époque et j'ai essayé de la voir c'est
un peu ce joyau du mont saint michel et
éric gagné est un homme d'affaires
redoutable il va faire de la mère
poulard une véritable marque et
multiplier les produits dérivés coûts
qui y allaient de bretonne confiture
caramel mais aussi celle de guérande
sardines en boîte et même thé anglais
battre et locales
le tout est fait pour des personnages
connaissent très bien les régions les
différentes contrées françaises
aujourd'hui la petite aubert s'est
transformé en un groupe agroalimentaire
qui emploie plus de 1000 personnes
eric vannier possède même sa propre
usine à 20 km du rocher et l'homme
d'affaires en veut toujours plus tant de
jours il a prévu d'exporter sa marque à
l'autre bout du monde un business qui
lui laisse peu de temps pour gérer au
quotidien ses fonctions de maire alors
il délègue à jan galle ton son adjoint
des côtes
une bonne façon d'éviter les natifs du
rocher il est plus accepter parce que
pour les montois et les plus montois que
moi voilà donc voilà c'est tout et puis
voilà c'est chacun chacun sa croix
absolument absolument qu'un élément
comme ça une fonction loin d'être de
tout repos pour l'adjoint car depuis
quelques années la colère gronde au mont
saint michel
le lendemain matin c'est à ponte en sont
à 9 km du mont que nous retrouvons
frédéric ridel le natif et grand
amoureux du rocher grâce aux recettes de
son restaurant il a pu s'offrir cette
maison moderne 250 m² ici fini les
vieilles pierres
c'est carrelage du sol au plafond comme
tous les autres commerçants
fredo n'habite plus sur le rocher on a
habité pendant des années il ya aussi
quelques inconvénients
donc j'ai le promener les enfants à
l'école et pas de ramassage scolaire est
le plus une tong qui avait pu l'école
non plus au mont-saint-michel boucle
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de vie de
village sur le monde seulement des
commerces à l'heure du café le journal
auquel donne encore du grain à moudre à
fredo le râleur on y parle des grands
changements en cours face en ce moment à
voir le jour de mon ami chaleur dont peu
il dit seulement que les gens sont
contents de céder
[Musique]
des mécontents car le monde est au coeur
d'un chantier pharaonique
[Musique]
dix ans de travaux 230 millions d'euros
un ouvrage titanesque mais nécessaire
car au fil du temps à cause des
sédiments
le mans s'est ensablé pour qu'il
redevienne une île en 2006 on a
construit un barrage qui rejettent les
sédiments au large
aujourd'hui on construit un nouveau pont
pour y accéder et pour que le paysage ne
ressemble plus à ça un énorme parking
l'accès au mont est désormais
strictement interdite aux voitures
et c'est justement ce qui fait râler
fredo il se sent tout bonnement
étrangers en son pays
c'est la nouvelle barrière qu'ils ont
fait l'ong a maintenant on rentre sur
notre part nous tarde d'attraction là on
est pour être embarquée on peut plus
rentrer chez nous ont peuplé les chaînes
comme on veut faut qu'on passe par une
barrière commente pas blanche qui
l'attend est limitée à 30 km heure sur
cette route a désormais au mont saint
michel
tout le monde doit se garer sur ces
parkings situés à deux kilomètres et
demi du site
les visiteurs doivent ensuite prendre
une de ses navettes pour arriver au but
fredo lui laisse ça aux touristes
en tant que commerçant il a laissé
passer valable uniquement pour les
livraisons mais fredo en profite pour se
garer au pied du mont toute la journée
ce qui est totalement illégal
bon c'est vrai qu'on s'y met quand même
cinq six voitures de gens du mont saint
michel qui sont là dans la journée il va
peut-être avoir une quinzaine 15
récalcitrants à une prune du 7 euros
j'ai arrêté de fumer comme ça ça fait
plaisir d'être une surtout à cause des
travaux
la guerre est ouverte sur le monde entre
la municipalité certains commerçants des
irréductibles et comme d'habitude c'est
l'adjoint au maire jan galle ton qui va
au front
[Musique]
ce jour là il doit faire voter la
construction d'un nouvel accès au mont
une sortie de secours en cas de grandes
marées problème il va falloir percée à
droite de cet échafaudage dans le rocher
et ça c'est un sacrilège pour certains
en toi on ne doit pas toucher à leurs
cailloux alors à quelques heures du
conseil municipal il se fait alpaguer
dans la rue par les anti travaux si le
grand c'est généreux s'est jamais au
moyen âge le monde est classée à
l'unesco dompter signal si c'est au mont
saint michel c'est au mont saint michel
au moyen âge il ya eu la même politique
que maintenant le mont-saint-michel leur
était jamais construit à cette époque là
alors ok moi bah côtoient tout leur dira
alors là cet après midi ça va être
costaud latérales et un gilet pare
balles sans gilet pare balles mais avec
beaucoup de détermination
l'adjoint au maire va affronter le
conseil municipal composé exclusivement
de commerçants du monde comme géraldine
vallier une montoise pas commode logique
c'est la cousine de fredo
c'est horrible c'est horrible ce un
crime de guérir elle la plus tenace
opposante aux travaux mallem le break
l'une des rares habitants du mont il a
su le rocher à la commune à la commune
alors si la commune mais la commune est
là pour en parler on va en parler
le ton est donné alors je vais vous
présenter la demande d'autorisation de
travaux très vite
géraldine failli interrompt l'adjoint du
temps parce que c'est un jeu des
habitants alors là si on veut tous
contre avec ce qui se passe le préfet
rappelant la vessie et donnons pas ce
que ça va retarder les choses
seulement voilà autour de la table les
conseillers anti travaux sont
minoritaires
alors qui est contre eux
cette autorisation demandé par la drac
alors un contre pied pour jet de voir
messieurs la séance est levée à la
majorité les travaux sont votés une
partie du rocher sera bien détruites
pour construire une issue de secours au
mont liberté sont confisqués et si oui
c'est une honte
yan tu ne peux pas dire que tu aimes le
monde qui n'aiment pas le monde puis à
voter la destruction du rocher c'est une
invention des scènes peu de plaisir
après une lutte sans merci la bataille
du jour et gagner pour l'adjoint au
maire et l'équipe municipale
mais pour les habitants il y a un grand
absent
monsieur le maire
bien loin du mont saint michel à dix
mille kilomètres de là c'est au japon
que nous retrouvons eric vannier
monsieur le maire est avant tout un
homme d'affaires il a décidé d'exporter
sa marque dans ce pays de 128 millions
d'habitants il en est persuadé
l'image de la mère poulard peut séduire
ici c'est un pays test avant d'aller
conquérir l'asie ce matin il va
inaugurer son nouveau restaurant loin
des vieilles pierres du monde dans cette
galerie commerciale flambant neuf au
milieu des restaurants de sushi
l'enseigne française à comment ça va
très bien oui super bienvenue dans votre
restaurant à ya pas de fautes
d'orthographe
c'est très bien ça commence bien très
bien alors
mais à l'intérieur un problème lui saute
aux yeux est la guest prodigieusement
faut remonter ça je veux dire décès des
montagnes de produits c'est pas 4
produits il se balade on est quand même
mais quand même la marque de biscuits au
japon étrangères et on se retrouve là
dans nos propres établissements avec un
minimum syndical
c'est pas bien ça c'est pas bien ce
restaurant eric vannier la penser dans
le moindre détail
si le personnel et japonais ici tout
doit rappeler la france entre les
cuivres de villedieu les poêles ou les
photos du mont saint michel
on se croirait presque en normandie
c'est bien fait c'est simple ce camp
c'est conforme aux manuels un décor
savamment étudiés dont le moindre détail
étaient consignés dans ce pavé de 200
pages la bible
eric vannier pourquoi faire ce qu'ils
veulent non non non on a tout ce qu'il
faut pour faire un restaurant depuis les
cuisines jusqu'à la salle en passant par
le personnel
à partir du moment où vous voulez faire
un concept et le faire respecter quoi
les dans tous les détails
un jour c'est important
eric vannier a prévu d'en faire une
chaîne de restaurants des franchises
qu'il espère vendre en quantité mais
pour y arriver il va d'abord devoir
convaincre les journalistes et surtout
cette critique gastronomique très
influente
je suis ravi de vous rencontrer ah
désolé si dans l'autre sens et je suis
critique gastronomique et directrice du
magasin c'est elle qui fait la pluie et
le beau temps dans le monde culinaire au
japon si le concept lui plaît
le public pourrait bien suivre alors
pour la séduire
le businessman a sorti son atout charme
la mère poulard en personne
j'ai endossé l'habit de lumière sa nièce
fanni qu'il est déguisé pour l'occasion
et il n'hésite pas à la faire passer
pour la descendante de la célèbre
cuisinière
je la trouve très ressemblantes avec son
aïeule effectivement jeunes c'est elle
que l'on retrouve sur les paquets de
biscuits de la marque
mais eric vannier compte surtout sur son
autre star
[Musique]
sa légendaire omelette
la critique manque de tomber en pâmoison
elle est énorme j'ai jamais vu une
omelette aussi grosse ah non j'ai jamais
vu ça
[Musique]
exceptionnellement la recette a été
adaptée aux goûts asiatiques
l'omelette ici n'est pas cuite au feu de
bois et elle est surtout moins baveuse
mais apparemment
la célèbre critique est conquise c'est
bon c'est très savoureux et c'est
goûteux à mon avis ça va plaire aux
japonais ah oui j'en suis persuadé pour
eric vannier
c'est une très bonne nouvelle je pense
vraiment que les japonais vont adorer
ah oui car elle est vraiment mais
vraiment grosse est délicieuse et vous
la trouverez bonne c'est ça non mais
vraiment je n'en ai jamais vu une aussi
belle et surtout une aussi grosse
ah oui avec son feu vert de la presse
eric vannier va pouvoir vendre beaucoup
d'autres franchises à cet homme monsieur
mac a souri le pdg du groupe numéro un
de la restauration japonaise
c'est lui qui a acheté la toute première
franchise et c'est un peu comme s'il
s'offrait un bout du rocher le
mont-saint-michel ça fait rêver du
japonais cognon et la mère poulard ça
représente tout ça voilà
croquant se demandera d'abord il va
rester au japon pour faire beaucoup de
mère poulard et après laura un voyage
gratuit là bas et les japonais n'ont pas
fini de se régaler d'omelette eric
vannier a prévu d'ouvrir 600 restaurants
identique en cinq ans dans toute l'asie
de quoi gonfler un peu plus son chiffre
d'affaires estimé à près de 30 millions
d'euros et pour le monde certains sont
prêts à toutes les folies
il ya six ans silvera a tout quitté pour
pouvoir réaliser son rêve encore cet
ancien chauffeur routier a démissionné
de son travail mais surtout il a fait
déménager toute sa famille près de 300
km depuis tour et s'il a acheté cet
ancien presbytère
c'est juste pour pouvoir se dire un jour
proche pas jouer le mont saint michel
est déjà hors ceux passionnés rêvent de
pouvoir admirer le mont saint michel
depuis son lit seulement voilà pour
l'instant il faut se pencher par la
fenêtre à six kilomètres de là entre le
lampadaire et l'arbre le mont saint
michel en modèle réduit courra la chance
d'avoir le mot juste à côté quand on le
voit d'une des chambres en profiter un
peu trop loin pour silvère qui aimerait
bien en profiter dès le réveil
alors il a eu une idée positionner une
série de miroirs pour pouvoir projeter
l'image du monde jusqu'au lit conjugal
mais tu te mets comme moi d'accord
manière et de façon à ce que je vois je
vois l'angle si je trouve une fixation
un projet très ambitieux et complètement
fou par anita sa femme
mais si cette école d'accepter un coton
va tenter on verra bien mais ça vaut le
coup d'essayer
mais si le vert est du genre obstiné je
pollue aux méthodes sont mont saint
michel il le verra du lit quoi qu'il en
coûte
et à faire des trous dans les murs
depuis l'âge de 7 ans sylvère est obsédé
par le monde il a lu des dizaines de
livres sur le sujet sheila par la guerre
alors
j'ai déjà les bonnes idées quand même
ouais faut que je gagne de l'anglais ça
j'ai passé l'angle et pour pouvoir vivre
son rêve jusqu'au bout sylvère est même
allé jusqu'à changer de métier mais un
jour bonjour
cet ancien chauffeur routier est devenus
guides de la baie du mont-saint-michel
tac vous êtes toujours d'accord pour
aller faire un petit tour dans la baie
du mont saint michel
ma foi je vous invite à me suis même
parti pour son groupe de touristes
il a prévu ce jour-là une boucle de
trois heures autour du monde alors là ça
va glisser un petit peuvent marcher
doucement vous faites des petits pas et
beaucoup de tenez à votre camarade d'à
côté comme ça si rac et glissante radio
tu as le ballon avec silvère les visites
n'ont rien d'une promenade de santé
s'ajoutent le genre ça va tout le monde
impeccable avaler c'est sympa au départ
quand ça passe entre les orteils
1 s'il a gardé sa gouaille de
camionneurs il ne regrette pas son
changement de vie on vit dans un tel
endroit tel endroit tellement magnifique
on filtre est très difficile de le sort
de s'enlacer c'est pas possible à mes
yeux c'est que j'aurai merveille à
chessy surprend c'est tellement beau que
ces deux là bas j'ai su certains se dit
mort aujourd'hui
sylvère fait partie des quarante guide
de cette immense baie d'authie mon jeu
grande comme cinq fois la ville de paris
juste derrière on s'y sent à monter quoi
me faire une balade comme ça c'est
magnifique
sous ses allures de plage paisible 7b
est en réalité très dangereuse
alors on ne descend pas ressort ressorti
que le descend pas ces flaques d'eau où
les enfants pataugent peuvent se
transformer en piège
approchez vous s'il vous plaît à ces
foutus je suis parti les sables mouvants
en moins de 5 secondes
le guide se retrouve en sable et
jusqu'aux genoux ceux là sont sages
il y en a certains vous allez arriver au
thorax en moins de 10 secondes
voilà là sachez les pointes croyez moi
bien voilà regardez bien là je peux
toujours tirer un tat la binette je suis
dedans je suis dedans terminée
le vrai risque des sables mouvants c'est
de rester bloqué pendant que la marée
remonte c'est alors la noyade assurée
est impossible de s'extirper de la les
pieds piéger en devient aussi lourd
qu'une voiture il ya des gens qui me
disent mais pourquoi pas mettre à
baudrier à la personne ap l'hélicoptère
est et fait remonter ça c'est une bonne
idée ça ça c'est pas bête ça
l'hélicoptère va monter de l'uimm est en
gros c'est la longueur de la teste à gré
l'on va même pouvoir voir ce qu il a
bouffé la veille le mec mais il va
gueuler d'après comptant le gazier
croyez moi bien c'est fortement
déconseillé qu'est ce qu'on fait eh ben
il va falloir inverser le processus
c'est-à-dire essayer de faire
redescendre au qu'on va avoir tout
autour de soi d'accord reprendre du
mouvement en tournant gentiment sans
forcer à elle c'est magique
et voilà c'est la magie du verre là bas
pour vous servir le mont saint michel
c'est le théâtre des plus grandes marées
d'europe deux fois par jour la mer à 10
km de là en cercle le rocher
[Musique]
cet après midi pour le groupe c'est
marée basse mais dans moins de deux
heures ce sera le processus inverse la
mer va remonter et submergé toute cette
baie lamari comment ce monsieur a raison
attention là la marée des gens très
nombreux ter aujourd'hui elle est pas
mal aujourd'hui est arrivé relativement
bien c'est à rentrer ici sur la voie
rentrer là c'est foutu
là bas on est mal il va falloir courir
courir courir du côté les airs du labo
voilà non les gens ne se rendent pas
compte
elle est belle la plage a avoué même
l'ajout retrouver des américains qui
avaient planté leurs toiles de tentes le
long de la sélune par là c'est quand
même assez unique quoi ils étaient
surpris en voyant les vicois arriver on
ne s'arrête pas dans ce top plus dans ce
top
notre groupe a le temps de rejoindre la
terre ferme mais pour les touristes
partis sans guide
le danger guette ce soir on attend la
plus grosse marée du siècle grâce aux
travaux de désensablement la mer gagnent
de plus en plus de terrain par endroits
l'eau va monter jusqu'à 3 mètres au mont
saint michel les gendarmes et les
pompiers doivent s'assurer qu'il ne
reste aucun touriste égaré dans la zone
ça va venir très très très très proches
et les gens s'en aperçoivent pas ils
sont là ils peuvent pour faire autre
chose comme beaucoup de monde en plus il
n'est pas impossible qu'on trouve voyez
propres est derrière là des gens qui
soient sur un rocher % pas que la mer va
arriver jusqu'à toi ok alors on y va
chaque année une vingtaine de personnes
se retrouvent pris au piège
encerclé par la marée
le commandant et ses hommes vont
inspecter chaque recoin au pied des
remparts du mont-saint-michel ivoirien
de portes plus tard ajoutant cependant
qu en eau de l'abbaye une autre et qui
balaie la zone avec des jumelles des
reçus pour vide en dernier recours un
hélicoptère est toujours prêt à décoller
ce soir
des curieux sont venus assister au
spectacle
ce qu'ils attendent c'est cette vague
qui arrive avec la marée le mascaret une
sorte de mini tsunami selon la légende
elle arriverait la vitesse dingue à
l'autre cheval mais en réalité sa
vitesse n'excéderait pas les 10 km heure
pour les gendarmes c'est le signal qu'il
faut évacuer la caf vous plaît en
quelques secondes la mer recouvre
entièrement toute cette étendue de sable
l'eau va maintenant tu es très vite
jusqu'à atteindre par endroits trois
mètres de profondeur
le pompier ont fait la démonstration
touristes voilà une seconde un danger va
pas loin
il ya des trous on est emporté vraiment
après ce nom là il ya deux minutes des
titres cotés et puis j'ai de l'eau on se
retrouve
l'eau va continuer à monter pendant une
heure les touristes vont devoir aller
admirer le spectacle d'un peu plus haut
un spectacle qui vaut le détour
les travaux de désensablement commence à
faire effet ce soir pour la première
fois depuis 134 ans le mont saint michel
redevient une île un spectacle devant
lequel viennent galt on n'a pas le temps
de s'attarder commence à envoyer au
maximum avant de finir sa journée
l'adjoint au maire doit gérer un énième
problème qui le contrarie les poumons
mont saint michel avant pour se fondre
dans des corps elle ressemblait à ça
mais aujourd'hui pour des questions de
sécurité
il doit tout changer maintenant qu'on
est sous vigipirate
on est obligé de retirer sa émettent un
sac transparent pour que visuellement on
voit s'il ya dedans c'est franchement
dégueulasse mais c'est ce qu'on m'a
imposé
et l'adjoint au maire n'a pas fini de
râler la fin des travaux de
désensablement est prévue pour 2015
les tensions ne sont pas près de
retomber au mont saint michel
[Musique]